على حافه انهيار اقتصادي بدت الولايات
المتحده بل والعالم بسبب سقف الدين
الامريكي الذي تم حل ازمته قبيل وقوع
الكارثه سقف الدين هو قانون يحد من المبلغ
الاجمالي للاموال التي يمكن للحكومه
اقتراضها لدفع فواترها وفي الحاله
الامريكيه فلا يمكن للحكومه تخطي مستوى
سقف الدين الذي حدده الكونجرس فيما يسمح
توقيع الاتفاق لحل الازمه لواشنطن بتفادي
التخلف عن سداد مستحقاتها
والسماح للحكومه باقتراض المزيد من
الاموال كما يشمل دفع تكاليف الموظفين
الفيدراليين والجيش والضمان الاجتماعي
والرعايه الطبيه بالاضافه الى الفائده على
الديون الوطنيه والضرائب المسترده وابعاد
الخطر عن الشركات والمؤسسات الخيريه التي
تعتمد على الاموال الحكوميه
الاتفاق يمنح الفرص لتفادي اخطار متعدده
منها انخفاض اسعار الاسهم بمقدار الخمس
تقريبا وانكماش الاقتصاد باكثر من اربعه
في المئه كما جنب البلاد فقدان سبعه
ملايين موظف لعملهم وعلى المدى الطويل كان
الخطر سيحيط بالديون الامريكيه ما يدفع
بالمستثمرين لفرض فوائد اكبر على واشنطن
لاقتراض الاموال لينتقل التاثير لبقيه
الاقتصاد فيصبح شراء سياره او منزل عبر
الاقتراض اكثر تكلفه للجميع
لمتابعه
المزيد لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا على
يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات